at polling stations in Florida Arizona
and Illinois wasn't just the democratic
process officials were concerned about
the rapid spread of the coronavirus saw
low voter turnout furious cleaning and
polling staff not manning the booths
over health concerns many voted early or
by mail but those that turned out on
Tuesday were cautious thanking one looks
sick or pr6
stay away that's the best you can do
well you can do is just try to stay
clean wash your hands limit any public
interaction if you can I mean I'm gonna
go home after this I'm not really gonna
be out hanging out with people so
officials in Ohio declared a health
emergency delaying their primary until
June the state's governor called it an
unprecedented health crisis that left
some voters disappointed I really wanted
to vote you know I wanted to make sure
my voice is heard especially you know
from other years and back in the past
where we you know despite the confusion
concerns and recommendations not
together in large crowds the night
belonged to Joe Biden the former vice
president now has the momentum delegate
counts and is seen by many as best able
to take on President Trump we're all
this together this is one for each of us
to see and believe the best in every one
of us to look out for our neighbor to
understand the fear and stress as so
many are feeling Biden now has a near
insurmountable lead over Bernie Sanders
he didn't address his losses on Tuesday
instead appealing for more federal help
for the pandemic we need to provide a
direct emergency $2,000 cash payment to
every household in America every month
for the duration of the crisis to
provide them with the assistance they
need to pay their bills and take care of
their families in his remote address to
the nation Joe Biden spoke directly to
Sanders supporters telling them I hear
you Sanders movement is still a powerful
force and Biden's appeal is perhaps a
sign of things to come the former vice
president wants to unite both the
country and the party and to do that
he'll need those supporters on board
and the Gallacher al-jazeera miami
florida